a dump truck came to the rescue of a
woman in labor during harvey's onslaught
andrea smith and her husband greg were
stranded inside their houston apartment
on sunday with up to three feet of water
inside outside when the strong
contractions kicked in neighbors called
on the fire department to send a truck
the new dad greg explained to cbs this
morning how everybody pitched in to help
the firemen and some of our neighbors
actually got in into the water up to
their waist and they kind of held their
arms together
kind of making like a little bit of a
change once we were in the truck they
put a big shower curtain over her to try
and keep her dry and out of the rain as
much as possible
and we were sitting on fire hoses
sitting on firehouses there they are
they made it to the hospital safely and
little adrielle there you go was born
early monday morning mom and baby we're
happy to say are both doing well and
they have
so thankful to neighbors that help them
out with three feet of water outside
that's not great
before it's all over i'll bet there'll
be some babies named harvey yeah
adriel's a very nice name for a little
girl
and the story of how she came into this
world i don't think her parents will
answer
that's right happy to be here yeah